where is it streaming to
I don't even know what happened there
oh
I don't I don't know I don't know it
weird man like
technology gets on my nerves sometimes
like there's no reason why that happened
no reason
give give you guys a couple seconds to
come back
I think they're
I think I need to
I don't know because it it was
it was extremely weird that that
happened
I don't even know if uh
if you guys are there
yeah I see people slowly coming back
man that's gonna like really
kill my buzz today man it's gonna really
kill my buzz
I hate when that stuff happens
and see what's funny is it kept the same
thumbnail and everything so like I I
don't know like I do gotta
fix one thing real quick I got to put
the attic show thumbnail back
it just made it to a completely new
thing I I don't I don't know if you guys
don't mind spam
spam the
the uh
the link in the comment section of the
last video
because I'm pretty sure it's gonna it's
gonna it's gonna make an on-demand video
I I would hope it would make an
on-demand video it's a weird I've never
had that happen
like both all my monitors are just
turned off and turned back on
oh there's previews for Diablo 4 going
on uh I'm not a big fan of Diablo it's
nothing against Diablo it's just I'm not
really there with Diablo anymore
all right so let's go over these games
I've reviewed
all right so
I think okay Halo We're Not Gonna count
the VR we're not going to count that so
we're gonna count
d uh Dying Light two
all the way up so that that's 10 months
ago so that's this year I did that on
February the 2nd so that's literally
almost a year from now you know
obviously not exactly a year because
we're not even in January yet but this
is this year so we got one two three
four five six seven eight nine we're not
counting this one 10 11 12 13 14. uh and
then I probably have two maybe three
coming so I will have reviewed 17 games
this year uh and I'm happy with that man
I'm happy with the support you guys give
uh you know you guys you guys show up
and I really appreciate it you guys show
up
I I
sounds like your video drivers updated
and that could cause your monitor to
turn off and back on it's it's weird
because sometimes it happens when I'm
playing a game I think
I might need to update my drivers and
maybe even factories I don't know
because I did get a new hard drive
I need to install that eventually
um you know because I had a job
interview today so I couldn't really do
a whole lot with my computer today
because I want to risk mess uh like
doing to the point where I couldn't have
access to the computer it wasn't worth
because when you're doing customer
service I didn't want to risk the
computer messing up and I can't show
them the like
because they were very impressed with
the mic I had in the camera which they
didn't really care about the camera too
much but they were impressed with the
camera I had and they were they're
really impressed with the mic quality
because obviously if you're going to
hire someone you want to make sure that
they can they can talk like clearly
what's up smooth
so you you off work what's going on with
you smooth you off work
I'm curious man I'm curious where is my
staff
I got one person coming
in a little bit
and I got one person told me 10 minutes
ago 20 minutes ago
are you home or at work I'm sorry I
can't remember what I asked you are you
home or are you at work
that's very important
home you want to jump in smooth are you
up to it
are you up to jumping in
or are you still feeling a little under
the weather smooth a little bit sick you
know he's a little under the weather I
don't know if he's feeling better or not
yeah I'll send you the link it's been a
while since you've been
and see my my obs
isn't telling me that I'm talking so
that that's a disaster
oh my gosh man
what I should have done before I might
have to keep my phone I sent you the
link smooth I'm gonna have to keep my
phone like briefly playing the podcast
just so I can
keep track of the uh the audio
I'll pause it for right now
I'll just check every now and then just
to make sure that you guys can hear me
correctly
you know the these mics aren't cheap
yeah man Sony knows that the heat is
coming and they stop you from talk
let me make sure that the security and
stuff is good okay we're good
very smart I think it puts Sony in a
corner it they've so far addressed every
potential concern
um
that
um regulators and Playstation have so
they address the fact that PlayStation
says like hey you know they're gonna
foreclose us they have the ability to
foreclose us and it was like all right
we'll do you one better not only did we
offer you 10 years we're offering
Nintendo and steam you know the same
agreement Nintendo is a bigger deal
because they've they The Last Call of
Duty they had I think was uh Wii uh
might have been ghost or the game before
that I'm not sure
um
and then you have steam where
Modern Warfare you know just came out on
Steam but previous games did not come to
steam
um and steam you know valve statement
also
thrashes uh PlayStations and uh I think
uh who else had like pretty much have
like oh like they're lined they could
change their mind and all this other
stuff
it's um
they the the only thing is that people
got left to really like sort of
challenge is the subscription service
meaning in in meaning that like oh well
they need to put it on PlayStation Plus
that which I think they I don't think
anyone has the right to say you know
Microsoft has to put it in another
Subscription Service they could say uh
not foreclose them and still make the
game available on Playstation add
Nintendo to the mix
um but the only thing that's left to
argue is that oh well the only
subscription service is going to be in
is in Game Pass well hey Disney has
exclusive Netflix has exclusives Amazon
has exclusives
um yes let it be so that like it's it's
it's a it's a power move uh I think they
met with the FTC today
um and this leaves literally Sony
obviously did not is uh it hasn't
accepted the deal so it makes Sony uh
looks bad and you know and I hope Sony
don't accept the deal so that when they
do close this deal the game don't even
got a release on that platform but
yeah it's it's it's crazy man
um
I think you know we we got K Mega
showing up and we we got dirt man we got
both of them man what's going on guys yo
you gotta show right when we bout to
talk about the juicy stuff you know I do
I do want to pull it back a little bit
before we get into the juicy stuff uh uh
because I want to talk about the Video
Game Awards and our expectations with
that uh but you know it's it's
interesting because
I want to talk about this Activision
thing so bad and you know what's funny I
was so tired of this Activision though
but I never expected them to hit the oh
the Uno reverse card on Sony uh but you
know let's let's get into the Video Game
Awards real quick man what what do you
guys expect from the Video Game Awards
um
well I mean
um I'm expecting uh so you mean like
specifically from Xbox PlayStation
Nintendo or just in in general just in
general we don't have to go like into
the specifics
yeah man I'm um I don't know what to
expect honestly uh I'm assuming there's
gonna be some big world world premieres
some new game reveals
um I'm I don't know what to expect to be
honest with you attic I I don't have any
game or or games or any idea what's
going to happen so whatever that show
I'm gonna be surprised I I I really
can't think of um maybe well you know
we're here in the room about maybe a
metal gear remake announcement that'll
be cool but I really can't think of
anything bro to be honest with you
yeah I actually uh he I want to ask you
guys a question you know we'll go around
the panel do you guys think Xbox is
going to be here in any way shape or
form we'll start with kids smooth first
um I think they'll be there
I think what would you expect
um well I would expect the games that
are uh probably their biggest games that
are coming uh next year
um I would say stop I want to see
Starfield and I want to see red fall and
I'd like to see Forza you know what I
mean um I think one of their games that
that that we don't have a release date
for should come there with the release
date whether it be the closest game uh
whether it be Starfield
um I don't foresee I don't think
Microsoft is doing a showcase before the
summer showcase so I think they gotta
leverage the game award so I'd like to
see a lot of Xbox there but
um I really want to see uh star field or
redfall
all right what what do you think Dart
you think they're gonna be there what's
going on man I do think they will be
there but I'm not sure if they're going
to have anything uh unannounced there if
they are there maybe they'll announce uh
like like Smooth said maybe a release
date for one of their previously
announced games
um I'm hoping they have some stuff there
you know some new stuff that'll be fired
like they have the last couple of years
but maybe because of this ABK at the uh
acquisition maybe they don't want to
show any new stuff
but they will be there
okay Mega well tell me man what you
feeling
I mean I
um I feel that Xbox will have a presence
there uh I think now that um I think
they feel a little bit more comfortable
about what's going on with the um
with the uh ABK uh so I
what I don't know if if this was the
same kind of situation that it was
um from what we was hearing just like
last week or whatever I think that it
would have been uh I think they would
have kind of held back a little bit but
I think that the third party is going to
be the uh the biggest uh the biggest
draw of the show I think that what the
third party is going to deliver is going
to be really crazy so I don't know how
much Xbox and Sony is going to deliver
but I do uh I do have a strong feeling
that the third party is going to really
come hard with it showing what they got
coming in uh 2023. so
the way that like
I'm hearing behind scenes is
don't expect big announcements there
like don't expect new IPS don't expect
anything drastic I do think that there's
a chance they could be throwing a
curveball because they said the same
thing when perfect art was announced
don't expect nothing the band Perfect
Dark shows up so there's a chance they
would but what I would expect
um I don't think starfield's gonna be
there uh maybe we'll get a we'll get a
red fall with a release date
um because maybe starfield's still up in
the air if they can actually hit live
deadlines I'm pretty confident Starfield
comes out in the next six months but
maybe they don't want to have to delay
something again unless they absolutely
have to so if they hold down that that
release date a little bit longer I can
understand that but let me ask you guys
a question if they don't show red Phil
here with a release date they don't show
Starfield who have a release date when
are they going to announce are they just
going to drop it on Twitter one day yo
starfield's coming out such and such day
because after the Video Game Awards
there's not an event to like E3
yeah that's true right that's a good
question that's a damn good question
their own like state of play or
something like that yeah that's that's
what I was thinking if they uh you know
do a uh inside that's why it's coming
back yeah
Excel event I mean because X the XO
event really doesn't have a timeline or
you know actual you know so they could
they could do that uh to kick off uh
2023 let us know uh give us a kind of a
indication what's coming because I don't
I don't think at this point that there's
any there's not going to be any more
delays for the three titles that we
already knew about yeah I think that uh
star field is going to come out when
it's going to drop red for redfall is
going to drop
um and Forza is going to drop when they
when they said it it was but I think
that
um
I I think it's just kind of like what
you was alluded to Atticus from what
you've heard is I just don't think that
they they were prepared to really show
off because they're still trying to get
this uh ABK deal to go through so
um I think that they could show a inside
Xbox or some of that nature starting off
in uh June I mean in January or February
and I think that that would be fine for
all the Xbox Gamers out there so you
know they've been so quiet uh because I
think we can all agree that you know
this has probably been the weakest year
even if something like game pass because
a lot of the times they get a couple
good you know third parties in there the
only one I could really think of is the
show I remember the show coming this
year but besides that you know they've
had really good Indies like really good
in these day and days they've had good
games showing up day and day yeah uh
playing still but you know what's
interesting is in February uh what
whenever
um whenever Monster Hunter rise comes
out for a Game Pass I feel like that's
one of the biggest games they've ever
gotten in Game Pass like one of them
because that's been exclusive in the
Nintendo platform monster hunter is a
big franchise like huge and the fact
that they got a game that's that sought
over to come over Dane day is Big to me
I think that there's a chance that
they've been like yo you know you they
like they're like let's let's let's get
this I feel like it's not they haven't
been pursuing third party I feel like
because of the Activision deal they
don't want to seem like they're in a
positive place like they want to seem
like we haven't really done much this
year you know what I'm saying we ain't
done no Game Pass deals like like they
don't want to give Sony any bullets to
try to take them to court with they
don't want to give them anything to
shoot them with because it's interesting
that at that point the Activision deal
is going to either be done
or they're going to be in court and at
that point it doesn't matter what they
do because they're in court so I think
it's interesting that they're getting
Monster Hunter rise after the Activision
deals ended because because to me it's
like they've been they've been fighting
with with one of their hands tied behind
their back because they are so scared of
losing that three billion dollars that
they were like okay 2022 we gonna take
it easy that day that year because this
deal is important for the brand in the
future and we don't want to make sure to
give Sony any reason
to stop us from getting this do you guys
think that's accurate or what
yeah I can agree with that yeah I mean
yeah the windows muster Hunter rise come
out on Game Pass
uh chat tell me someone in their nose
I thought it was in the first quarter
yeah I thought it was like January or
something like that yeah no I think it's
February it could be exactly so you
think that the deal was going to be done
before
um even before even even if the even if
the it's January the 23rd even if the
deal isn't done it's going to be at a
point where those decisions aren't going
to hurt it you know what I'm saying yeah
like because I feel like right now is
like the end-all be-all like in the next
month is going to be the most critical
if this gets passed or Not by the time
that comes out to me it's gonna be one
of those things where the decisions
already made it's not going to affect
anything you know what I'm saying and
maybe they don't see Rise as being a
huge threat that's why they were willing
to announce that so early
because that that is a a game that's
already been on the platform
uh so but I do feel like
Game Pass is such a huge driver and they
lost Starfield and they lost uh redfall
I was always like why didn't they try to
go after like Gotham Knights or
something to try to like you know make
their platform a little bit more
appealing for the holiday and that's one
of the reasons that I feel like they
didn't because they know that the more
they do with Game Pass now the more Sony
can go to the uh to the peoples and be
like look we can't compete with this
like look what they got going on over
there yeah Gotham Knights uh uh midnight
Sons can be a possibility
um yeah no I mean I I could definitely
see it I mean it it was kind of like
when I was making a prediction about
Scarlet Nexus I thought it would happen
right be an announcement at E3 or at E3
but it wasn't and then they announced it
um a little bit after that and so you
know I think the Tokyo game show
something yeah yeah so it was one of
those things to me where I think
I I think you're onto something addict I
think that it's the it's they wanted to
be they want to be as quiet as they
possibly can while they're 100 focused
on the ABK deal so then they could get
back to business to normal because
that's why I think that 2023 is going to
be a monster I mean gargantuan year for
Xbox there's no wait for E3 there's no
none of that I think it's going to be a
nuts year for Xbox not only just for and
and that's if we if they just bring out
three titles three AAA titles or
whatever if they bring that but Game
Pass alone is going to be
extraordinary I think there's a good
chance that we see
hellblade next year
the only way I thought hellblade would
get pushed back is if Starfield gets
pushed back if Starfield doesn't get
pushed back I think it's why are you
linking those two because I don't think
they're going to overlap them again I
think they learned that from Forza uh
you know and Forza is a little bit
different than it was with Halo but uh I
do personally feel like they saw the
drop from Forza and they're like look it
was like a learning thing even if it's
in Game Pass we should give them time to
breathe and putting hellblade near
Starfield I think would take all the
breath out of Starfield I mean uh
hellblade no I I I think it'd be the
other way around oh you think hold up
hold up yeah yeah okay you're trying to
tell me
yep yep listen to Uncle K Mega right
here
that's what I'm saying
I think that that game I've been I've
been I've been camping for them I've
been saying this for about about Ninja
Theory for a minute
Ninja Theory is going to be one of those
top Echelon Studios for Microsoft I
understand about the significance of
Starfield but I feel the star field
where it's going to get its main star
power is going to be in the PC community
because that because that's in their
wheelhouse I there will it will it will
still do well all you know still do well
on Xbox but I think on the PC end of it
it's going to be it's going to be
ridiculous hellblade on on the other end
is going to be that showpiece that will
get the Xbox Gamers to start throwing
that throwing that Xbox mud it it's
saying because it's going to be
beautiful and then on top of that it's
acclaimed that's it's going to be it's
going to it's already was acclaimed
Starfield is still it's going to be
acclaimed but I just think that the star
power for uh hellblade is going to be a
little bit more significant all right
since you since you you opened up this
this this Pandora's Box okay man I want
to go yes sir I want to go around the
table
and I want you to tell me what's more
important to the Xbox brand Starfield or
hellblade and white we'll start with
dirt
you know came back is the homie but I
gotta disagree with you here
um hellblade I believe is a is a huge
franchise but when it comes to a brand
new IP from Bethesda which is
something they haven't done in years
like brand new IP now we know how
Fallout and Skyrim on my Elder Scrolls
all that stuff is huge for Bethesda but
this is a brand new IP from them now
hellblade where I I love the game and
I'm definitely excited and for part two
and I agree with with what you said
about Ninja Theory and and the game is
going to give us XBox guys ammunition to
talk some trash for real for real
but
hellblade is not quite there as a big
name yet part two can make it a big name
but I just think this Bethesda
new IP and Nova was it 15 20 years first
new IP in over 20 years is going to turn
heads especially if it's critically
acclaimed which I believe it will be
just like hellblade will be awesome I
just believe
um Starfield is this at this point a
bigger deal now if we start to see more
and more of hellblade and you know some
stuff that really blows us the way
that's maybe that's one thing but right
now at this moment I'm still gonna say
Starfield is going to be the biggest
game for Xbox next year all right smooth
yeah
um
110 agreeance with Dirk griggity
um you got to think about
Phil Spencer and Todd Howard they're
close very close so this the it's an
IMAX acquisition even though it was big
for Xbox it was it's like very personal
with them and um you think about how big
um
you know Oblivion how big Morrowind was
for the original Xbox being the first
Elder Scrolls game with a major first
Bethesda game to come to console on Xbox
um you gotta think about it if it wasn't
for Xbox Bethesda would still be making
PC games
um you also gotta factor and um Oblivion
being it was supposed to be a launch
title for the 360 but it ended up being
a launch window because it got delayed
um Skyrim
um like
when you think about in isolation if x
if Todd Howard and all them didn't have
this Xbox stigma right let's say if they
weren't bought by Xbox yet right
Starfield would be a much bigger deal
than what it is now because of obviously
the hype you know what I mean it's just
like you know another Fallout it's a new
IP but if you think about it if it
wasn't like you know under Xbox right
and people was like okay this is
Starfield like you know how Starfall had
some hype you know when it was first you
know when they had that Bethesda event
like I think 2018. yeah you know it had
some it has some hype there's some
anticipation right because it's like all
right you know and if it remained that
right it like I'm guarantee you there's
like there's a lot of bias going on so
it seems like there's a little bit more
hate for the game now if we could have
seen saw we could have all seen the same
Starfield trailer
and would it let's say Xbox didn't own
it and it was a multi-plot whatever and
it was all like let's say PlayStation
stage or at the Bethesda event
it would have been the re the reception
would have been more positive than
negative right
so now it's under this extra scrutiny
and I think you gotta think about it
it's like okay
we know the capability of what Fallout
was able to do and Elder Scrolls were
able to do just on like IP alone so they
had uh star Phil has pedigree because of
like all right this is uh Todd Howard's
next IP and this Xbox's job and Phil
Spencer's job to really treat that like
there ain't no Halo there's no Gears of
War coming around the corner that's
that's this is the title I was like all
right we gotta treat this literally as
if this is Skyrim 2 exclusively for Xbox
so we have to go all in for it
essentially they have to uh now I'm
thinking about it like you know their
marketing really should start revving up
fairly soon and go I agree yeah because
it is that game and there's nothing Xbox
can release right now from any of their
Studios you know like I said hellblade
one was great but Hellboy ain't up to
that level that's what hellblaze 2 job
hellblaze two's job is to elevate the
hellblade franchise to the point where
we're like okay wait Hellboy 3 is on it
popping now we gotta make room for
hellblade three but hell like it's still
got it still got some um it has to prove
itself right Starfield essentially
doesn't really have to prove itself
because it's from the makers of Fallout
in Skyrim so it's it's it we it's by the
by name but that's the uh soft works
whatever by name it should already have
that anticipation Mass pill and the Xbox
literally has to treat that as the Halo
uh I I hate to say it because how Halo
turned out but it has to be Xbox's Grand
Marquis for the year it's the game that
they have to have a custom console right
yeah yeah
console it has to have a I don't know it
has to have a midnight release it has to
have all thing has to have a collector's
edition that come with a ship it has to
it literally has to have everything they
have to go all in because star field is
that IP at the end of the end of the day
which it could help late potentially be
a better game at the end yeah
potentially that's for us a way to find
out but in actuality what should be the
most uh hype and most pushed game from
Xbox right now is Starfield because they
owe that to each other you know what I
mean the Xbox owes them like the ability
this is not if if Starfield wasn't
bought by Xbox Xbox would be paying for
marketing rights yeah just like they got
with like Skyrim and fall they would be
paying for marketing rights and then you
know they'll be doing the marketing that
way they just have to go all in
Starfield is the game there's no game
bigger for Xbox coming out in 2023 other
than Starfield
I think okay can I can I can I have a
rebuttal okay for both gentlemen all
right okay so let me give you all some
history right here all right so
before the Cinemax deal what deal was
that that got everybody hyped
that was in 2018 it was the original
five yeah yeah of course yeah you say
Ninja Theory is one of them and when the
Ninja Theory was one of them
let's not forget let's not forget
what the vga's done with Phil deer with
the vgas and one of the dopest trailers
in game in whatever that was
bro you mean to tell me that rocks the
gaming World when they seen it and
everybody was like what is this and I'm
like this looked like Cinema and then it
was like and then the year after
what did they they shocked everybody
again and don't tell me because I was
watching the streams you got streams
people were standing up going crazy this
is your game this is your game are you
kidding me this is exactly the red meat
or I should say the green meat that Xbox
Gamers has been waiting for is that over
the shoulder triple a big budget title
to throw at the swing that mud back and
say this is what Xbox can do right now
when you give them a full budget then
you give them time I feel y'all
and I feel you guys about Skyrim I mean
about Starfield I do I'm not I'm not
disputing that part of that it should be
the bigger game I just feel personally
it's because of the of what
um everybody is is is is is is loving in
the especially in the media and where
people talk about is those graphically
strong story driven games and I feel
that sinner was uh you know uh the
hellblade 2 is going to be that game to
propel Xbox to the next level while star
field will be a compliment as well and
in in it most likely probably will sell
more but I just feel that that's going
to be on the PC side I feel that the
hype level of of the hype level between
both of them is going to go to a
hellblade but I I'm not you know what
I'm saying but I I you know if I'm wrong
about it I'm still happy about it
because both games are going to be XBox
exclusive so that's why that's my type
hey hey Megan at the end of the day
that's what it
[Music]
you know but I just feel that that's
what Xbox is is everybody's been waiting
for for Xbox is that over the shoulder
AAA game just to kind of throw at the
God of Wars at the at the whole damn
Sony template right now at this point so
it's gonna be I mean this is for us us
box bro I'm telling you yeah yeah yeah
yeah for the boxes so it's it's what
we're going to live for so that's what
you know that's what I think the hype is
going to be a little bit stronger for
that game let me give me a claim here
here's how I feel all right all right I
feel like
you both are right uh in in different
ways I feel like
we have been asking
what is the results of these Studios for
a long time when they bought the
original five okay you got these five we
ain't seeing nothing from them really
then they got uh double fine and
obsidian we ain't seeing nothing from
them really sure yeah Exile we've seen
gains from them but it wasn't small that
was done from them you know because you
would expect that their next game is
going to elevate the preview stuff
because at that time there were
independent developers and they didn't
have a backing behind them like that uh
so I think hellblade is going to show
Microsoft can do third person uh over
the shoulder
Sony template stuff
um and I think the reason I'm leaning
more towards Bethesda is because
Starfield is going to show it's like I
don't do I don't do like like uh what's
what I'm looking for I don't do Sports
but I know when it comes to like Nate
like name me like a sport uh a player
from like any sport that used to be that
like used to be amazing but now they're
like average now because of age and
stuff you know what I'm saying it's like
equivalent to having one of them people
on your team and you trying to show the
world that they used to they who they
used to be you know what I'm saying like
play uh Bethesda software Studio used to
be literally one of the best studios
around when their games came out it shut
the internet down
when Skyrim came out when fall Fallout 4
I won't even I'll give it a little bit
of that Fallout 4 but it's not even I
don't even think Fallout 4 had
the the height that the previous games
had because they went away from a lot of
the foundations that made their games
their games let me get this Super Chat
real quick
got a 10 super shot from Jujutsu 50. I I
think I got that I think I did some of
my favorite real XBox guys appreciate it
man appreciate it man only rock with
real only rock with real uh we stay away
from the snakes man we stay away from
the snakes snakes in the in the in the
PlayStation community and the Xbox
Community because they stakes in both uh
so like
I think Bethesda is going like if if
Starfield comes out and it hits good
people will be like yo
Bethesda back like the people who made
Elder Scroll and you know I said on IOP
you can debate on history that Bethesda
software Studios might be one of the
best Studios that's ever existed they
have Morrowind game of the year they
have Oblivion Game of the Year Skyrim
game of the year Fallout 3 Game of the
Year like most of these games got game
of the year and if they didn't get game
of the year it was a game that was like
people consider one of the best games of
generation like in in ever like I
remember Fallout 4 lost because I think
I think it was Dragon Age Inquisition
Fallout 4 lost to that uh you can't
count New Vegas because obsidian made a
New Vegas uh which I want to tell you I
would get in so much trouble if I say
that so I'm gonna continue going uh
fallout
um Fallout 3. I I don't know if it got
game of the year but I remember one of
them got and I think it was Fallout 3.
Skyrim definitely got game of the year
and uh in Oblivion and Morrowind I'm
pretty sure both of them got game of the
year like besides Rockstar
who else be hitting like that
they batting like seven like seven and
one
six and one
they they in all the games they've made
because people like to throw Fallout 76
in the mix did they jump drop the ball
76 yes I'm not gonna say they didn't
regardless if it wasn't the studio that
made Starfield and all these other games
it's still part of their their their
jacket we're going we're going to shoot
both into these you can't blame one
without the other but naughty dog I see
people say naughty dog you know I will
give them that they're close to it but I
don't think they're even on that level
like and I think that's the point here
it's the point is Starfield comes out
and it takes off
Microsoft has
a studio that used to be in the Golden
Age
and they have them back but they have to
prove themselves after 76 that they can
still make those games
yeah and I think that's the issue now as
far as naughty dog you know The Last of
Us Part Two uh people say that's the up
and down game I know gameplay is
fantastic but I know a lot of people
didn't like the story
um I know a lot of people that didn't
like Uncharted three they thought it was
okay but it wasn't anything fantastic
they loved on Charter two
uh Last of Us Part One was probably one
of the best games that's ever made but
they have an up and down scale people
didn't think here's my thing like
besides
Fallout 76 people that like Bethesda
games they have a hard time picking off
their all their games because all their
games are on that level in my personal
opinion I feel like Naughty Dogs up and
down they do more ups but they do have
downs but that's that has one down in
like 20 years
and that's just my opinion on the matter
as far as when it comes to
hellblade hellblade is going to show
what the system could look like it's
going to be that how that that eye candy
it's going to be that look look what I
can do I think it's going to show that
that original studio and I think
hellblade is significant because it's
the first game that was truly
uh developed under Microsoft and I think
that's going to be important too it's
like I said there's a lot of different
uh different aspects to this and I don't
think like one can can can can claim
them all there's different ways of why
this is working in the way it's working
now I want to ask you guys this wives of
hellblade 2 and Starfield come out ahead
oh
Hey listen if hillblade comes out next
year I'm it's gonna hit that game is
going to hit so I feel it's gonna hit
too if if listen I'm going to say this
if that happens I think Us Xbox fans the
real Xbox fans were like us on the panel
right now there are some other guys in
the community that we all know that that
stay true to Xbox even during the
difficult years right
um even during this year you know
um 2022 we didn't have any first party
triple A games it wasn't as bad as like
a year like 2017 because we had no games
and no road map you know what I'm saying
2022 was it that's bad because we can't
get them legs beat boys
yeah I mean we got that fight man you
ain't smooth but so but 2022 wasn't as
bad because we know the road map looks
tremendous and if that happens next year
all of the waiting
all of the way to eat three kids we used
to be saying I don't like ice everywhere
every year every year man I used to you
know what's funny after a couple years
we couldn't say it anymore man how many
times we're gonna keep saying this like
like I remember it was one year where
Phil said it was the best year in Xbox
gaming and then the next year it was
like I think it was the year recore came
out like it was supposed to be there he
said that before it came out wasn't like
yeah it was the most it was pretty
Quality 16 was pretty good at anybody
that Quantum break record Quantum break
uh years four gears four years forts
that came out that year yeah yeah
in a rare replay come out that year too
much I remember that yeah I remember
right replay there was a little bit of
leaks on that but no one believed them
because it was such like a crazy project
like all of rare's games in one
collection I remember people saying that
ain't real that ain't real you know
what's crazy if Master Chief Collection
wouldn't have gotten leaked before it
came out that would have been probably
the best announcement 2014. yeah yeah
yeah that was yeah um yeah cheers
I'm just excited for 2023.
um I think we all deserve it man we
deserve for 2023 and Beyond especially
the four people in this damn podcast
especially smooth man yeah yeah
smooth like what's funny is like me dirt
and K Mega you know what what uh dirt a
little bit more than me and Kate Mega
we'll dip our toe in it we might jump in
the pool the toxic pool every now and
then right smooth just do a cannonball
on that [ __ ] every week
he's in it oh man so yeah I was in it
every week there for a while and yeah
yeah you were yeah but she wasn't you
wasn't a regular member on weapon well I
think that's different but I was on I
was on uh multiplayer yeah bro oh yeah I
would say that actually actually rocking
them so yeah
that's probably more yeah
at least got they at least keep it
somewhat cordial internet hey I was just
a guy in the in a chat just listening
Mega back then and I was like you used
to be uh fighting back then Z was still
Xbox so he was fighting
but it was like it was a bunch of ponies
he gonna swing one way or the other
until the actual show started right
right you didn't he he swings whatever
ways he needs a swing for his show to be
let that happen now when I got
introduced to the pony contract that's
when I knew the things changed and I was
like nah bro I'm not I'm not interested
I'm sorry you know so you know I just
was not interested but yeah I
yeah it was rough times I mean it's it's
been long overdue I mean that
when scalebound and what scalebound
didn't release what happened to
Crackdown three
um you know when when you know I I say
this quite a bit uh when Rand told me I
was just happened to be in a party with
him and and a dealer and other ones and
and he came out and he said like Mega
this you know I know you've been talking
about this game a lot but man that game
is bad I'm like okay but they can fix it
they'll delay it no no no no no no no
when I say bad I mean bad and so he's
like I I just think that Phil's going to
shut it down I said don't say that and I
guess I got two and I guess I got two
emotional
still speaks to me but not like he's
supposed to be that day because I was
bro I was hurting my four I was like did
you see Kevin popping up on Twitter so
you know what this bull stuff that ran
just told me
that was one of those confidential
things and stuff like that I mean now I
just could be saying because you know
and sure enough like a day or two later
that's when Phil said uh
oh my God it hurts so bad it still
stings so to see the sea to get to this
point uh I see from there to this point
and then of course I I was strong about
sea of Thieves I mean I was wrong about
bleeding itch but I was right about sea
of Thieves I said it's going to be one
of those games
I was literally the other way around I
was wrong about cities and I was wrong
about please
because I was four bleeding yeah I'm
still completely manager I just I hope
that once they get done with help late
they'll come back to it I don't know bro
I think I think there was a time where
me and we were the only people playing
bleeding edge on in the entirely
yeah
you know what's sad I felt like I
understand why they didn't do it but I
felt like what they should have done
they own all this property now they
should have turned bleeding edge into
their own Super Smash Brothers with
their characters yeah
they should have done that they should
have reworked the way the fighting
system worked on I think it would have
worked out but you know it is what it is
I don't think Microsoft I think they
they needed more modes because the
people people everybody just they needed
more players to be in more modes first
off well true but I think the biggest
I'll finish what you're gonna say Okay
mega no no no my just point was just
just it was going to pretty much
probably agree with what you was going
to say but you're saying like I it it
just it did it needed more time in the
oven and that's uh and that was what it
was I mean like when we played it at E3
I mean it was a hit out there like I
mean I was and I was telling everybody
and I was passing out codes and stuff
and and uh but it they just had a
problem of getting out their content
because they was working on other
projects and then they was having the
problem with um you know just letting
the gamers because Gamers wanted to have
the option of playing one mode or the
other and they kind of was forcing
everybody to play that one particular
mode which that was the least popular
mode and they didn't add any modes even
though they said that they were and then
it just was all she wrote at that point
so I but I still care for you love you
bleeding ninja steel you know what the
thing is is that they um
yeah I think they they stopped the
services and the thing is that that was
one of those games that like in order to
get bought out by Microsoft like you
have to release this because no other
publisher probably sure would right
um but they shouldn't have abandoned it
but like that they have I guess like 14
people made that game uh I feel like
yeah but they I think they added two
characters since this release I think
they they could have done a couple more
maps a couple more modes just like give
it a chance like those other games of
the service could and just like hey like
it just could turn into something
um because you you still had like
obviously xcloud coming you had um you
know the Next Generation consoles that
adds extra life to it all right let's
make sure we enhance it make sure we
have our like you know 4K and 120 frames
that game as is can run at 4K 120 frames
a second on these current consoles just
to add that extra like um so this you
know if you see it now it looks better
all right um it's something like I don't
think it's a game they should have let
die cause I think they were going
somewhere with it um it's just that it
may be you know it released at a bad
time hell they could have held on to
that game for another another year and
made it a lunch title for the for the
series X and that [ __ ] I still think
that that's hope I still think that
there's hope smooth I really think I
think I think that game is dead I think
that you think it's dead yeah they shut
down the servers they're gonna reopen
the servers I I don't know oh man oh my
goodness that game gone man
look I personally feel like it you know
I will never know if this is true or not
I personally feel like one of ninja
theories
uh requirements of being bought was we
almost had this game out the door can we
finish it and I think Microsoft let them
finish it to make the process of buying
them easier because even if you even if
they even if they sold and they didn't
let them they would have morale down
because they just made them kill a game
they've been working on for years right
uh so they thought okay let's let them
finish it let's let them get it out the
door see how it's reset recepted and
then we'll go from there there's a
difference between the reason that like
grounded is still getting support and
bleeding edge is it now I do feel like
bleeding edge had the foundation there I
do I feel like what you should what they
should have done is they should have
they should have hired some contractors
to like get us Master Chief uh
um the dude from Gears uh yeah I don't I
don't know which one you guys would want
Marcus or it doesn't matter uh get get
us like four characters four popular hey
uh for popular Xbox characters put them
in there and then restructure the game
in a way people would like and then see
how it goes after that
but they they didn't do none of that
they're like okay it ain't good we're
good
must have been so bad that they said
forget it yeah the plug yeah I see the
drain in the toilet in the toilet going
back and back it was like can we get it
no we can't get just let it go and you
know what's crazy because Crackdown
still works uh because I've I've
recently played it uh
yeah the multiplayer yeah yeah there's
still a couple people that play it yeah
you have to have six to two it's it's
six to ten people if you can get six
people to play the service will work and
there they added a couple of new maps I
had no idea oh wow okay mag could be
streaming he get the whole audience in
there there's a total of eight people
playing cards
it's about Crackdown you know now we're
just talking about like mess-ups of Xbox
I don't know how we got in this
conversation but Crackdown three I felt
like had so much potential and then that
multiplayer just destroyed that stuff
and it's not that the moment yeah that's
what I'm saying they would have just
scratch that multiplayer early in
development and focused everything on
the story I felt like we would be
talking about Crackdown 4 right now I
really and truly do like people want to
talk bad about Crackdown Crackdown
messed up a lot of things but that
campaign was fun I have a clip on
YouTube of me trolling smooth for like
40 minutes like literally because I had
a a I had a fully maxed out agent and
smooth didn't so I was picking up his
his car and throwing him across Mass
distances and there's this one time
smooth sucks at platforms he's just not
good at them he he he was like yo can
can I get in a car and you just and you
just pick up the car and do the
platforming for me I was like sure
smooth and you should
just
history
we're gonna move on though before uh uh
before Smooth gets brought up on charges
more than he is yeah that was uh yeah I
I see where you're going with that one
I mean it was live so it's not like
people yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
all right it was a good idea so because
the platformer got annoying towards the
end of the game bro
all right so let's let's talk about this
this 70 dollar Xbox they announced it a
couple days ago which is interesting
they'd I don't think our next topic the
you know the golden Nintendo steam I
don't think that was planned I don't
think that was your traditional PR plan
but we'll talk about that here in a
second but this was definitely planned
the way that they wrote this out uh you
know I actually knew for a few hours
before it happened and I was just like I
guess I guess Jabari and JW are about to
have a date because I'm going back to
bed I ain't dealing with this so I went
back to bed woke up to like 50
notifications you know how like when you
get so many notifications it says a
number and plus and mine said that twice
in like 30 minutes uh so it's just like
how you guys feel first off we'll start
with uh we'll start with with uh k-mag
how you feel when you saw that 70 price
and did you see it coming uh yeah I know
I talked about it on grg
um months in advance even before Phil I
said the writing is on the wall uh
because when they were talking about
raising the prices to Game Pass doing
the family plan I'm like if they're
going to make these type of moves then
obviously there's something that's going
to be happening going further and that
could be the 70 price 70 price tag
um sure enough Phil I think it was like
about a month and a half ago somewhere
around there where he he announced that
look we can't keep games at 70 forever
you know I mean sixty dollars forever
and everybody then I think kind of was
bracing for the impact some people was
thinking that it will probably be when
uh it would only be Xbox uh series uh
games only uh and you know and I was
thinking like man this this could come
next year sure enough we already got the
announcement next year it's gonna have
Starfield and and I guess all of the
Xbox first parties gonna be 70 bucks uh
I'm still gonna hold that same energy
like I do with PlayStation 70 games I'm
not I'm not paying 70 dollars for no for
no standard game well it's easier for us
to stand on that that uh that Cliff
because we have King pass well yeah
that was going to be my next point but
I'm just saying even if there wasn't a
Game Pass
um if you know I if a deluxe edition
Ultimate Edition I I buy I'll pay money
for those that's fine but for a standard
version and that game is still going to
be put on the Xbox the Xbox One
no I'm not doing it so that's why the
reward system is has been vital uh you
know I've talked heavily about Gotham
Knights
um but I did not pay 70 for Gotham
Knights I got Gotham Knights for 40
bucks
um because of my rewards
um uh
it's going to be the same way but I mean
it's but it's going to be a lot easier
and I think the reason why there's not a
lot of Xbox Gamers that's got the the
tiki torches in the in the in the in the
pitchforks is because of the fact
um is that it's on the game pass is
going to save the day so what this will
do if it's kind of an incentive to kind
of get people to join uh the game Game
Pass uh family and and if they have a
problem of paying the 70 bucks I know
that there's still those those Gamers
that will die on the heel that will
constantly say well look seventy dollars
is to stand I mean seventy dollars is
fine with me I just want the title I
want to have the the feel of that it's
owned as long as you're paying for you
know if you pay uh two years into Game
Pass
you don't have to worry about nothing so
you know what I'm saying the most likely
if it's one of those games it's going to
go on sale and you're going to buy it
anyway that's usually how a lot of
people operate anyway when they're
dealing with Game Pass games is that if
they like that game good enough and they
feel like that game is going to have the
potential of leaving they're going to go
ahead and buy it at the best value so
that's kind of like the strategy I'm
going to kind of operate look and see if
I can find deals somewhere if I really
want that game day one but I mean as
long as those games are hidden a Game
Pass then one I mean it's a it's a win
for Xbox Gamers and that's why I think
that softens the blow a hell of a lot uh
in my opinion
all right it's smooth man what what's
your feeling man uh you you spoke very
highly on uh not buying 70 games when it
was on Playstation are you do you have
that same energy of Xbox or have you are
do you are you here to officially
retract statements oh no no no no you
took a drink oh okay no no
um my opinions are the same it's the
same I I've been
planned I don't like buying them all
PlayStation I have no issue buying them
like so I just I'm not going to buy on
my Xbox I have Game Pass I've been
bought a 60 game on Xbox I haven't had a
bought a 40 game on Xbox
I have Game Pass as long as their games
are on Game Pass I don't care if they
raise the price of 100 now and the
reason why I say this is like all right
let's not go that far let's not say
hundred dollars nah nah here's the
problem right now people want to let you
know play games you make games this is
where you can get past fighter okay all
right cool cool cool worry about my
pockets all right so
I was told
over the course of two years now
that seventy dollars are away is okay
it's quality and I was told that in the
defense of PlayStation right since
PlayStation went that long ahead there
they've released games that are worth
seventy dollars uh okay I pay 80 for
return okay all right so now I had to
sit there and shut my ass up for
complaining about seventy dollars all
right all right whatever cool I'll even
buy a couple of them right did that
now the Xbox does it don't expect me to
complain because I've already been I'm
used to it now I it's a normal thing why
do I need to complain I don't buy games
remember why do I need to complain like
I play all my games and Game Pass I
literally got to a point right
thanks to PlayStation thanks to 2K
thinks the activations thanks to all the
the Publishers that jumped out in front
of this 70 price thing up front it
literally changed my habit of buying
games day one I haven't bought literally
haven't bought a single game day one
this year I've been waiting for uh
discounts I've been waiting for Game
Pass or whichever comes first like in in
it hasn't even gone it wasn't even
strictly for Saturday games 60 dollar
games fifty dollar games there's games
literally that I'm interested in that I
didn't buy day one and so since my
attitude has changed and my habits have
changed on my game consumptions I don't
care at what price the games launch at
anymore I I I I it doesn't matter and as
long as Xbox has Game Pass like I said
as long as they have Game Pass and that
that price holds for a little bit
I'm fine matter of fact even if Game
Pass goes up as long as Game Pass eight
sixty seventy dollars a month it's still
cheaper to have Game Pass than to buy
the game outright for every game that I
wanted to play so no I have no issue
with Xbox raising the price
um I'm not going to complain now it's
two years it's two years into the
generation them dudes been buying games
at 70 bucks getting ripped off uh ripped
off for two years straight and then you
want me to complain now the Xbox did it
two years later
like it was in it was a word that
inevitable inevitable it was going to
happen I'm happy that they weren't in
the last ones the people who did not
rush to do it was Capcom Sega Bandai and
Xbox and
what is um
it's it's a movie or something he's like
I'm inevitable oh no it's Thanos that's
what he says I'm inevitable all right
Dart yeah I'm curious to hear your
opinion on this man because you you
definitely I I heard a little bit of
your opinion uh you know uh shout out to
uh the podcast uh which one is it you do
WBZ wbg that's right yeah uh wbg man uh
definitely go go catch that out man I
wanna I wanna take a second dirt does
stuff different but it's just funny like
dirt that stuff where he'd be so extra
sometimes I'll be like yo I can't let
people know I'm watching this right now
piece of [ __ ] of the week like
and when I'm in his podcast because he
he does it on stream Labs I think and
what happens straight yards yeah stream
yards he'll click a button and I'll be
muted while he's playing some kind of
MP4 and it'll be the crazy stuff and I'm
like
there is stupid for this man oh man you
know here's what it is great content
um thank you Brothers hey so look I'm
gonna say this I never had a problem
with seven dollar games never never
would I take a shot at PlayStation
Fanboys yes we have MLB the show and
Xbox game pass y'all got to pay seventy
dollars yes I might have done that but I
say all the time I had no problem with
70 games I mean through the 90s we've
seen Super Nintendo N64 games I I know
it was because those games were
cartridges but still some of those games
was 80 70 80 I remember that vividly
I never had a problem with it even when
I remember when the PS3 Xbox 360
generation specifically the Xbox 360
those guys went from 50 to 60. I didn't
really want to pay it but what am I
going to do I'm a gamer right
um there was no other option now when it
comes to options I was noticing um
some people you know saying and you
can't use Xbox game pass as an excuse
well why in the hell not
why in the hell not is is is Xbox game
pass uh
like a dream no it's real it exists so
why in the hell can I not use Xbox game
pass as an option
it's there their narratives has gotten
even more bizarre I look at situations
like that and I'm like it's like
equivalent to because Netflix sells
their stuff on um like you know DVDs and
stuff it's like I'm not gonna watch it
on Netflix I'm gonna buy a DVD of it
you already you already subscribed to
Netflix yeah like look I understand
where people are coming from they're
like look it's not necessarily they're
attacking Game Pass subscription on or
anything they're like we should be
paying 70 in general I get that but we
don't have that issue because we don't
have to pay seventy dollars option bro
it's like kids smooth said on Twitter I
can't tell you the last time I paid 70
for for for an Xbox game you know why
because I ain't not I can't tell you the
last time I paid sixty dollars for an
Xbox game like look and and I get it
people sit there and they they love they
love to act like they know what's going
on Microsoft no one knows if it's
profitable or not clearly they've said
multiple times it is but I guess you
know we'll believe anything Jim Lyon
Ryan says but for some reason you know
when it comes to to Phil Spencer and
Aaron grieber no he's just he's just
talking PR he's just talking to BR so I
mean so no finish yes yes let me finish
my my thought so that's something to
think that's some of the things I've
been saying like you know we can't no
don't do that now either the PlayStation
either you buy these 70 games or you
wait for the game to drop in price
there's no other option if you want to
play that damn game
Xbox first party we have an option we
can't for these guys to say oh no don't
use that as an excuse Xbox game pass
shouldn't shut the hell up you know it
irritates me where you can't you can't
just sit there and say we cannot use
that like I use this analogy on Monday
uh at it imagine in court the defense
has some hell of a evidence to get the
defendant off
having a playlist like no no don't let
them use that don't let them use it you
want us to debate you want to to say
don't use it to win his debate yes Xbox
charges 70 for their games okay like his
smooth said you know it's it's it was
inevitable Phil Spencer told everybody a
month ago that things are going to go up
now I would be honest if they raise the
console prices I would have a big
problem with that I have an issue I will
have a huge problem with that yeah I'm
with you on that one yeah but no
everybody's expecting Xbox game pass to
go up soon I I will not be surprised
like Smooth said if it's 67 yes that's a
damn problem right there but we're
expecting what five dollars at the most
Maybe
I'm expecting that they're probably
going to add a family plan so
I never had a problem with games going
to seven dollars it happens everything
goes up right everything goes up and and
even when PlayStation games went up to
70.
I I said we still want these huge
beautiful God of War Horizon forbidden
West type of experiences
but we don't but we still want to pay
sixty dollars for it that's not reality
uh listen we can go back to the Super
Nintendo generation as greatest Super
Mario Brothers world was I'm Super Mario
World was that was developed by eight
people
literally eight guys developed Super
Mario World
how many people develop games now
yeah a lot so they're trying to get
their money from somewhere we are Gamers
we love games and all I gotta say is
that yes Xbox did what everybody else
has done
I don't know anybody that thought these
guys were going to stay sixty dollars
the whole generation I I know nobody
thought that it was inevitable right but
I will say this again Xbox game pass
price will go up also soon we don't know
when but it's gonna go up but I'm going
to say this again if the console prices
go up that's BS to me because this is
Microsoft you can take the hit on
Console prices and and it's two years
into the generation soon to be three
years and it should be cheaper to
develop these consoles instead of you
know right that yeah consoles is always
depreciated you know just like game tab
so I mean that's the thing too it's just
like
um if people really want those games
um really want those games that bad just
be patient and wait for a cell or wait
till your rewards uh come up because the
difference because I've signed up to
Sony rewards years ago and I have 130 to
140 games on my PlayStation 4. I I can't
even buy a game game on on a Black
Friday sale man that's that's how bad
their reward system is so over there
Sony so you know I I go ahead and I I I
beat a Persona Royale
uh through Game Pass I got enough to go
and buy three games because I'm saying
so it's like
oh you know that full-fledged 60 games
but I'm saying like you know if games on
sale for like 10 20 bucks or whatever I
can get I could I could work it to where
I can finagle to get like three games so
it's it's one of those things to me
where it's like or just save until the
next game that I want to get it's not
it's it's really weird to me that people
like what Dirk was saying would try to
dissect certain pieces of what is really
happening and then just to have a
narrative like I I absolutely it's just
like what Colin Moriarty was saying
about well you can't count star field
you can't count these get you can't
count uh uh redfall but yet people you
know ignore about the Insomniac
situation because Sony didn't acquire
Insomniac until a year after uh
Spider-Man 28 uh 2018 came out so I mean
like so so what are you talking about so
should but anyway it's it's one of those
things to me where it's like people say
the weirdest and craziest things just to
try to have people say the darnest
things yeah yeah and then you got people
I I don't know I'm like sometimes I
wonder when people say some of this
crazy stuff who is this giving them the
likes who are this and who are these
people that are accepting this as as
this is the god the gaming gospel it's
crazy you know who mega you know I know
that are liking this that are are
spreading this out that's given give
them like man they're just lying through
their teeth just making it up as they go
and they're just running with it as
though this makes sense it's just it
it's bad thing to me okay just to
clarify
and I think Dirk knew what I was doing
yeah yeah yeah
because I know we're having another
night he was out of there as old no
um I have added the calling topic
I've been sick and I ain't been able to
talk about these statements and if you
guys can't stay around that's fine we
don't like I could do that by myself but
I gotta talk about these statements so
let's move on to the calling topic
because I I feel okay I don't care about
my it's 70 you want to pay for them pay
for them you don't don't pay for them
eyes myself they got me by the balls I
got to pay for them because they're not
going I'm not gonna not play the games
uh fortunately I'm a Content carry and I
could use that excuse to pay the seventy
dollars and in my phone I gotta cover
them but that's that that's as far as
I'm gonna go all right so we're gonna go
on the calling topic and that's one hour
because I think I think we all disagree
what Colin said here you know first off
let's not be crazy here okay like
calling is entitled to his opinion even
though it's crazy as hell and he
shouldn't have said some dumb stuff like
that and I get it I think Colin has a
all right let me get these superche real
quick we got a one uh 179 I don't know
what currency that is serum Grant never
played more than never pay more than 50
they still make profit I feel you on
that and then two dollar Super Chat from
certain Grand uh fomo is a psychological
disorder uh fomo what is he saying fomo
beer uncertainty and um uh a spirit
missing out or something like that
they're missing out yeah yeah I I don't
I don't even think it's missing out I
just have I can't control myself I
really can't like if there's a game I
want to play I can't stop myself from
not buying it day one like I just can't
do it I don't know why it is how I am
too man I'm the same way all right so
let's talk about Colin Colin Moriarty
went out and he said that you can't
count games like
um like bethesda's games uh you know all
the studios that Microsoft has bought
you can't count them because they
haven't been made from beginning to end
under under under
Bethesda under Microsoft's watch all
right so first thing I want to say is I
get where he was coming from this uh he
was saying I gotta see how they interact
with these Studios and how they nurture
them and make better games than they
were making currently but Colin came out
said
I know that Final Fantasy is made by
another student we're going to give them
credit for that I know that for smoke is
made by another Studio but you know
we're gonna give them credit for that
like I just feel like he said it in the
wrong way I don't think he meant it the
way he meant it Colin has a bad issue
with not thinking when he's speaking
about certain things you know and it's
just like dude you know a lot about
PlayStation no one could ever take that
away from that man he's a very
knowledgeable person on Playstation but
I do think he has a horrible
uh opinions when it comes to Xbox
because he doesn't truly understand he
hates Xbox what's going on Xbox right
yeah he doesn't truly understand what's
going on in the Here and Now with Xbox I
think he might have been very up to date
back then but I think as of right now
he's just not up to date on what's going
on in the day today he said multiple
times that he he is beyond blacklisted
so I don't think Microsoft's really
working with him in situations like that
and I don't think I think he gets so
frustrated on certain things that's
going on in the gaming industry that
sometimes he'll speak off of emotion
when it comes to those scenarios uh you
know like with the Bethesda thing he
went out on a limb and said I'm willing
to bet you Starfield is going to
PlayStation well he was wrong he had to
take that back uh so it is what it is
but I want to hear your guys's opinion
on you know uh we'll start with Dirk
because we start with everyone else
there when you heard this it was it was
out late it was a very hot take how was
your opinion yeah
um my opinion it wasn't good I I did a
video about it I said it's absolute BS
and look I I there was a comment left in
my video
um that the guy said I believe I said
this on WBZ last Monday the guy said if
if you grow an apple or buy an Apple
it's still your damn Apple I don't give
a damn
bro listen
we know that Xbox has helped out you
know they really help double find
um you know we heard the interview with
Tom what Tim Schaefer said they removed
all of the bosses and Microsoft buying
them they were able to include all of
those bosses back into the game and that
game wouldn't have been what it was if
they didn't have the bosses in that game
um you know Starfield has been in
development under Xbox for a few years
now I know the game was in development
before Xbox acquired thing but you know
he's been in development under Xbox for
a few years look man they bought them
flat out
if you buy a car if you buy a used car
right
is it your car you damn right it's your
car you bought it the the one thing I
will push back on that is we have seen
scenarios where Microsoft has picked up
Studios they're not really like utilized
what they used to do like that was all
in Microsoft and I feel your reason the
thing is is it might be a new resume but
it's just like you know when bethesda's
uh uh Bethesda Austin Bethesda software
Austin made 76 but all of Bethesda got
the blame for it like regardless if it
was years and years ago people still see
that as the current go the current too
you know they don't want to talk about
like Minecraft and how well Minecraft is
done under Microsoft you know they don't
want to talk about that they don't want
to talk about how Psychonauts cut a lot
of the portion of the game out but when
they were actually purchased by
Microsoft they let them put those gains
back in there they don't talk about how
Wasteland 3 took a lot of the bosses out
of the game but when they bought them
they put them back in the game they just
want to talk about the few two mistakes
that Microsoft has made in the past 20
years
like what are some examples that's
literally the only thing is the only
example okay and now you can't even you
can't even use rare anymore because CDs
has done so well and they're also
working on ever wild and even though
it's gone through some development
problems it's still being made it's not
like it got scrapped so you know yeah I
understand what you're saying um
but rare is really the only example uh I
know like oh okay now I'm magic of those
guys they pull rare off of games and say
yo let's do connect games we understand
that was a whole different regime but
I'm going to say this
this Phil Spencer regime right now
they're giving these Studios car belongs
to do what they want to do we heard the
interview with Ninja Theory and they
said they probably didn't wouldn't have
joined Microsoft if they would have to
do what Microsoft wanted them to do like
uh some type of game that's a service or
some type of monetization and they said
no they gave us conference to do what we
want to do you could probably say the
bungee handling was a mishap too because
they wanted to work on Destiny under
extra oh you damn right
though yeah
but it's like I said like when it comes
to stuff like that like they're still
gonna have to take the heat even if it's
10 15 years later until until they start
showing because Microsoft didn't buy
Studios like that until recently you
know I think besides those five they
bought 18 the last one was Minecraft was
Mojang and before then I couldn't tell
you the studio before then because it
was before I started covering the
industry so I can understand Coalition
maybe was the last one before that yeah
but I think they built that though no
they but they bought blast Black Tusk
and they renewed right into it I can
understand well let me say this real
quick I agree with Colin when it comes
to I need to see what they do when the
money is being funded through the
studios the talents being upgraded I can
understand where he's coming from that
but to say that we can't count Starfield
when I think it's you could easily come
out and say look we need to see what
they do under Microsoft but these
Studios and their brands and the games
they're coming out with show they got
talent they got quality and they got
really good games and I think you could
have left it at that but Colin didn't
leave it at that he said no we ain't
counting none of that stuff it don't
matter if if they make in the next game
he kind of acted like another Studio
it's like they're making a studio with
like the prime team and then they're
firing all of them in another Studios
taking their place like
crazy
I mean I got you though but I I I do I'm
saying there's one quick thing making
I'm done yeah I disagree with how he
said it and I disagree with what he said
yeah right so I didn't hear it go ahead
oh okay no I just wanted to just say
that look I I it was just like when I
did my video talking about uh what Colin
said I like I respect Colin I think what
he does is I respect him and like David
Jaffe even though they could got to go a
little cuckoo for Coco Puffs a little
bit with some of their theories but I I
do respect their work you know I I can
listen to it and understand some of
their things but this right here was
just for the for for the for the bass
this was just for the PlayStation uh
Fanboys the PlayStation stands to get
them back on board because you know if
Colin does this Colin will go on a roll
and he'll start saying stuff that Xbox
Gamers can can uh relate to uh or
something that that PlayStation fans do
not like and then next thing you know he
knows where it's toasted butter you know
and then that's when he comes in he'll
say these crazy narratives because that
that you know that that I mean the
reality is you know I'm saying look he
wants to get paid like he'll say so he
he knows he knows where his toast his
butted so that was one of those things
for me is that you know he was not
thinking uh right then and there about
everything else that happened with
within Sony uh and how they got built
because they have they have if anything
I would look at that as a success story
for PlayStation especially how they uh
had had to turmoil with Nintendo and
then they jumped in and and then said
okay we're going to get into the video
game business ourselves and we're going
to hey we're the biggest company right
now uh out there so we're gonna start
we're going to start flexing and that's
what they did and so again
well Microsoft is doing the flexing
right now the PlayStation fans don't
know the history or they don't want to
remember the history are looking at
Microsoft it's like oh they're the big
bad guy because they're this big
conglomerate when they totally forgot
about what Sony was doing what they were
doing when they were the big
conglomerate in the gaming business at
the time so I just think that
um
it's it's asinine and just going back to
one of your points that I was going to
push back on when we were talking about
like the stuff was rare the mistakes and
mishaps and stuff like that it was just
think about it as as any artist right
their first one or two albums might hit
but then they might have that third
album that just is terrible and people
might think of but people might think
like oh man I don't know are you think
the people are going to not buy the
fourth album because they because the
third album was so bad or or because
they know about the pedigree of the
first two albums and how good they were
they're going to give it another
opportunity so I think that like trying
to keep on uh standing up on the old uh
way that Microsoft used to be I think
that that ideology needs to die because
the one thing that PlayStation fans do
is hold on to that Mystique of what
PlayStation what made Playstation grade
during the one two uh era and it it was
somewhat in the third and then and it
kind of I think four four was a great
year for them especially console y
console uh uh uh console sales wise game
uh games in abundance like PlayStation
one and PlayStation 2 not even close and
the PlayStation 4 era PlayStation 5 it
doesn't look like anything uh comparable
to what we've seen in PlayStation's past
but people still want to hold to that
Nostalgia of what PlayStation was great
so why do we still have to you know I'm
saying so why do Microsoft can't change
the foot and people change and thinking
look at this new era of Microsoft and
see that they are putting in the work
not still holding on to the old uh to
the old way that Microsoft used to be I
I agree so what was you gonna say smooth
I like I guess I missed this whole thing
uh like I said I've been out of the loop
uh over the past couple days but like so
Colin said pretty much Xbox can't get
credit for like the new Studios they
acquired if they're like successful with
their upcoming you pretty much said that
even if the games are successful you
can't count them because they weren't
developed by Microsoft they were games
already almost out the door uh when they
were Acquired and Microsoft helped them
get them over the Finish Line I think
that's pretty much what he said he's a
butt face dude I'm sorry like oh wow
that's just ridiculous like I no he he's
doing the same thing that these other
PlayStation Fanboys do when I be having
these random Twitter arguments
every time I bring up they want to bring
up like oh well Psychonauts don't count
because of uh it was back but I was like
dude the game that you would have got
during the kickstarter was not going to
be the game of the year nominated one
that you got dude so just like hold it
the game's been delayed three times
since they've uh acquired the studio
it's not like they they announced the
game that game was supposed to come out
a hot minute ago and it would have been
like a three hour 75 Metacritic game
that's what it would have been Xbox once
they put the bosses in and I was told
that that's like the best part of
cycling yes is the boss yes and the
original game without Microsoft had no
bosses they went back and put them in
the game yeah so it would have been
literally just a you know a crowdfunded
passion project and we know how passion
process father so no I'm giving I'm
giving Xbox credit yo I don't care like
how Mondeo they could have owned them
for three weeks man like like I did they
deserve uh credit and I don't know
what's the point why take the credit
away like what does that do for you
because what does it do like I don't
understand I think what it is is they
don't wanna like and it's not just
calling like a lot of the people on that
side of the the pawn seems they don't
want to give Microsoft any type of props
until they actually see the game being
beginning to end that's why I brought up
hell played because after hellblade
there's no excuses that game was started
and finished under Microsoft's umbrella
uh it's like I said I understand where
certain people come from you know I do
understand where Collins coming from a a
point I do think he he didn't word it
the way he should have I think he's just
like look I want to see what Microsoft
does under Microsoft especially you see
like the initiative having issues three
four three I can understand why you
would see okay is the management going
to make sure that they're on track I
think uh that's okay criticism but at
the same time it's like look man
we've seen
uh we've seen Todd Howard literally come
out and say the first person I called
when 76 burnt up in my hand was Phil
Spencer clearly they've had a great
relationship and
Todd Howard literally said there's
people at Microsoft right now helping
them work on Starfield
so it just it is what it is you know uh
the only people that's going to prove
these people wrong is is Microsoft um
now Colin is one of the people that he
did come out and he said he was wrong
about the Bethesda thing he will come
out if there's plenty proof that he was
wrong and admit he was wrong but there's
some of these people ain't nothing you
could do man you could have a 96
Metacritic every game and they'll be
like that's not the kind of game I like
so it is what it is until Microsoft
comes out and they start shooting
showing the fruits of their labor we're
we're going to continue to get comments
like this because until they show that
this is what we're doing this is what we
about this at this lifetime uh and it's
like I said like if you're on the fence
of buying Xbox just stay on that fence
because I can understand your mentality
it's like you don't have one you got to
see what they're actually doing with
these Studios I can understand that what
I don't understand is why podcasts
literally talk about it weekly
you ain't buying an Xbox just leave it
at that fam all right let's let's move
on to the last topic man uh
Phil Spencer you know let me get the
timestamp please one hour and 20 uh one
hour and 25 six minutes 26 minutes yeah
we called him here okay Mega and kid we
called them the time stamp police
because uh they come at me man uh
they'll come at me in the comment
section and say why nobody called the
timestamp police we call them the time
step Mafia the picture I need I need
them come on they'll put you three foot
under if you don't get them those time
stamps man no no see dirt dirt let me on
the nice little like do them live like
when you go to the next topic just put
them in your in your description and
move on like it takes like three five
seconds and who would better to team
when the next topic starts than the damn
host of the podcast
cool yeah okay oh you're you're muted uh
dirt
all right so let's talk about this uh
Xbox versus PlayStation man we have seen
the biggest colossal fight of the
generation in its Xbox trying to take
home PlayStation you know they're trying
to marry PlayStation but but uh you know
you got you got PlayStation over the
Xbox is trying to marry Call of Duty and
Activision but you got PlayStation over
there like the bitter ex-boyfriend that
won't let it go man these he's the
person that pops in right when they
about to get married and say I objects
and uh so you know we we got some stuff
going on uh obviously we've had back and
forth we've had Sony literally coming
out there and say there's no way
at all we can ever make a game that's
qualified on Call of Duty and then you
got uh Playstation the Xbox coming I
said Call of Duty is special
it's a game like every other first
person shooter which I think is is
absurd if you think about it uh but
last night Phil Spencer came out on 11
o'clock at 11 o'clock okay keep in mind
that is not PR that is spur of the
moment we got to deal with Nintendo
let's announce it because this is a
reactionary move this is not planned
this is going out there it's like how
can we sh this lets me right here guys
this is what can we do to shoot
PlayStation's kneecaps off looks okay
let's get let's get Steam and let's get
Nintendo let's do 10-year deals and then
they're going and then they're pushing
the chips all in they're like and it's
literally like you sitting there man you
got pocket aces push all your chips in
the middle and you just what PlayStation
what you gonna do what you gonna do so
we're gonna start with we're gonna start
with kids move man what was your
thoughts when you saw this
uh
uh I thought of like a hole in one like
I think um the first thing I did because
immediately I saw a tweet and made a
video um I think this is their like
pretty much them like pretty much
securing this deal and pretty much
ending the arguments from any regulator
whether it be the FTC whether it be the
CMA whether it be the urine your
European commission whatever
um and Sony
um Dave if you guys realize Xbox has
addressed every potential concern that a
regulator or competitor may have
Regulators okay how will it uh affect
employees and stuff like that workers
they partner with the CWA they got their
backing unionized and all that stuff
they can't now they can't even bring it
as an argument that's protected okay
oh what about foreclosing them from
platforms okay well we offered
Playstation three years they they said
no okay we went back offered them 10
years he said oh now they're just being
petty on top of that let's go put it on
Nintendo who's never gets Call of Duty
oh yeah let's extend our uh to the
biggest uh storefront on PC Who had who
went gears without a Call of Duty game
God this year and we're gonna uh uh
agree to uh do like another decade with
them guaranteed okay so in that case you
don't need PlayStation because Nintendo
right now Nintendo player base right now
at this point is bigger than PlayStation
so um if they want to cause problems
like hey we got Nintendo you got Steam
and we you know there's the cloud and
everything which opens uh the get next
to the game on platforms that didn't
have access uh to the game before and of
course Game Pass we're actually making
the game of Cheaper to people otherwise
if it's if we the game stay as is it's
gonna be 70 bucks where we have a
cheaper or in for the game so it's like
okay what's the argument right now even
without any of this stuff Xbox is doing
if none of these Regulators have
actually a real reason to Sue or block
the deal there's no real actual reason
to sewer or block the deal I feel like
because of the number is so big they're
looking for any little thing and they
just need to make an argument for the
sake of making an argument but there's
no real case against this deal and this
really honestly believe it or not should
be the easiest deal uh Microsoft should
be uh to close because they are more
than prepared there's no way Sony has
this much power
a clout did like all right everybody's
gonna look out for Sony's behalf really
I feel like there's got to be some like
low-key like money being exchanged I'm
sorry like I'm not I don't like doing
conspiracy stuff but these companies are
trying extra hard you know what really
hit me is when Phil Spencer said in that
interview
it's it's like Sony is talking to
everyone but us to get this dildo and
when I heard that I was like damn I was
like
Sony got to be greased in hands or
something I'm not even trying to sit
there and say they're bribing people hey
I am I'm trying to say that they're
bribing people they something's got to
be going on here now maybe they ain't
bribing people maybe they truly have
that much influence and clout in this
industry but it's just like to sit there
and tell the number three that you can't
buy a company because number one don't
want you to you know what's funny Brazil
I love Brazil you know I I've never in
my life thought about going to Brazil
but after I saw that how they addressed
the uh where we're here to look after
the Brazilian consumers not Sony's
interest I was I love these people I
love these people let me get these super
chat before I pull it off the dirt we
got a two dollar Superman from Hector de
Macho Man
is it me or has Twitter been quiet here
lately dark this is
it was on fire yesterday until Phil
tweeted that yeah yeah
seven dollar game box yeah did you guys
see that God of War is it coming out to
2025
who you know uh Wolverine yeah yeah and
what's funny dirt when we were sitting
here and people were sitting there super
chatting saying we got Spider-Man and
Wolverine next next year hey I said
every time you guys are out of your damn
mind if you think Wolverine coming out
next year right right you got 20 uh 17
Super Chat from soaring Grant Microsoft
making games available on every platform
to expand access to games and to create
profit PlayStation in-game is to
restrict access to games only where they
can make the biggest profit which one do
you think is uh quote unquote the
players uh what's funny is you read that
he is 100 right and for some reason
they're trying to reverse it like
Microsoft is doing this as an
anti-consumer look it's crazy and Sony
is not it's it's crazy so so dirt tell
me how you feel man what's going on man
well first let me read this quote from
spill from Phil Spencer that you just
mentioned
um verbatim he said from where we sit
it's clear they're spending more times
with The Regulators than they are with
us and trying to get this deal done
yes Phil Spencer is talking that that
will show those shots bro this is crazy
to me because
Phil Spencer Satya Nadella this Brad
Smith guy they all seem very confident
you know I remember months ago they
asked field spirit so you think the deal
is good they said yeah I'm pretty
confident the deal will get done because
they knew Sony listen they've been
talking to Sony since January about this
they knew way back then just uh Sony was
going to try to block this deal they
knew it when they offered them three
years I mean yeah like three years they
was like no that's inadequate okay fine
Xbox
well what they're doing right now I
absolutely love
he tweeted that I was in the bed I was
like whoa is this the real feel
expensive or is this some guy asking
like no this is the real feel experience
so let me read these everybody say
something go ahead you know what came
back you know
is this is this Hardware Sales true
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah Microsoft
outsold them in November
oh Addy you need to see that bro oh I
gotta make a video that's tomorrow's
video but I think that's is that in the
VG charts one no that's that's just one
week all right so the thing is you got
to figure out oh that's one week but the
other weeks they won in North America
too yeah I'm so glad so if they they
in the week that uh gotta worked out
they won the week before I don't know
about the we got to work yeah I think so
you think all right so overall after you
do tally em up for the month of November
do you think
all I'm saying well I think that they
they won by like 200 000 in that picture
yeah
that week exactly I am so glad I didn't
bet King in that bend the knee I'm sorry
he was trying so I was tempted you guys
I was tempted but I was like you know
what I ain't giving his knees back this
soon and he been trying every week he
tried to get me to bet with him I feel
like kid smooth on weapon with a black
Bond like except for kids move caves to
him almost every week I know one thing
about me at it I'm waiting till the
official and and PD numbers come on and
let me tell you something I have so many
receipts of like like when they first
announced the Xbox series as price drop
so many guys came at me like
it still doesn't matter PlayStation 5 is
still gonna I'll sell it so I said okay
you know you should do if that's those
receipts that you have you should make a
stream if you're just reading them yeah
that's kind of what I was thinking I was
gonna do yeah it's gonna be sweet it's
gonna be sweet yep keep those um always
bookmark always bro let's not you know I
keep receiving no you screenshot you
don't bookmark they delete that stuff
they delete it fast the moment something
happens they absolutely that's true
that's true oh okay well then screenshot
it yeah definitely screenshot yeah
um
so let me say this before we go to you
make it I just I just love what Xbox is
doing
okay smooth actually broke everything
down all of the concerns the FTC the CMA
the E all the concerns they had Xbox is
answering them
they're like
like the concerns was like we don't want
the games taken away from PlayStation
from other platforms Xbox said Hey
listen we're not taking anything away
actually we're adding platforms we're
adding Nintendo the last card on
Nintendo was ghost in 2013.
and it ran horrible we're at right rest
in peace to these card games on Nintendo
dude you're gonna you're gonna unless
they got a new Switch coming out soon
right I don't know yeah
so it's I I just love it man Xbox is
just showing listen we want this deal
done PlayStation continues to cry about
Call of Duty
but this deal means more to this Call of
Duty for xBox right
um so like I said I love it man this is
like incredible this has been given us
so much content these last few months
every time we say we're tired of talking
about it some more stuff comes out and I
love talking about it and um XBox and
Phil Spencer there this deal will be
approved and even I'm starting to see
some leakage from some PlayStation
Fanboys they're starting to say well the
deal will probably be improved but maybe
Sony can buy EA
Sony does have the money to buy EA but
they'd have to liquidate like half their
company like right like they don't have
the cash they would have to borrow the
money now PlayStation is a very
profitable company that Sony in itself
they do make money they do have the name
to get that kind of money but
investors and board members would never
let them spend that kind of money
because that's too much of a risk
absolutely so yeah but that's about it
man you know that's I love it that's all
I want to say I love it and um this deal
will be finalized bro it's Xbox had a
plan in place bro they had a plan in
place okay Mega all right man you know
what's funny I had a positive stream
because I listened to about three or
four minutes I was like you know what he
coming on attic show I can't hear his
bars right now I gotta hear them live so
so tell me what you what's your thought
man what's going on all right man so
kind of like what I was saying on on the
stream today was basically like look man
I've never seen a company that was uh in
the Statue of what Sony is has fallen
from Grace the way that they have and if
you don't believe me all you got to do
is just look at what everybody else in
the industry is saying when Sony made
this public the first thing that they
thought that they were going to do was
get the public and the media on their
side the media started but then kind of
held back like well I don't know right
and then the mud slinging started and
then Sony was you know because they they
felt like they had to clout
tore down EA tore down of course
Battlefield and EA tore down take two
tore down uh tore down Nintendo and of
course tore down Xbox
and and even in the point of your you
have a relationship with Activision and
you're kind of treating Activision as
though they can't do they can't do push
can't have any pushback towards you
because it's that God is their game it's
not yours Sony
and then when I seen that the uh the one
lady I think it was the CEO pushed back
and say we will take this to court
um they don't want to do we have we have
you we have the back of Microsoft and we
will take this to court to get this deal
finalized oh yeah yeah that was it I
said oh you messed up so because now at
this point let's just hypothetically say
that that uh Playstation did throw a
monkey rich in this and and made this
deal go through you think that
Activision is still going to work with
Sony and make it and have them be the
market and have them uh have the
marketing rights to Call of Duty it was
just like I was trying to say to people
and they didn't believe me
um but I said Xbox can mess around and
have the marketing rights to Cod and to
Battlefield because you think EA is
sitting here looking at them and saying
oh man you just desecrated you forgot
about Battlefield one that sold that
that that that was comparable and sold
just about as many copies as you as a as
Cod did that year
and you're just going to talk about
Battlefield 2042 and just dog us out
like that and then of course you know
the love law there's no love lost
between Nintendo and and Sony anyway
yeah go ahead I was gonna say you know
what's funny like people understand when
Xbox makes statements to save this deal
when they say you know Call of Duty
nothing special people making Call of
Duties like we know what's going on but
oh yeah when it comes to Sony you're
seeing like they're causing morale in
their own Studios by saying yo we can't
compete with that they none of our
Studios can make it and I'm sure Bungie
over there like fam why'd you buy us
then like what are we doing over here
like everybody everybody at Sony studio
should be looking at the should look at
me looking at them cross-eyed like what
you think a naughty dog or Insomniac or
someone there Santa Monica Studios is
saying like we can make a game that's
kick ass you just make us make remakes
just like the rumor that there's going
to be another another remake yeah
another remake so what the hell is the
problem is that Sony themselves made it
all about Call of Duty because it hits
their bottom line Microsoft is looking
at the bigger picture they're looking at
King they're looking at older games to
help with backwards compatibility in in
game steps and they're looking at
bolstering Game Pass Sony does not want
to do two things Sony does not want to
pay Microsoft to have Call of Duty on
their platform and the second thing of
course it is actually really three the
second thing is they don't want it on
Game Pass day one for Microsoft but the
other factor is that Sony cannot have
those perks that they've been having uh
still one marketing that's crazy they
still want marketing and they want those
those perks that they was having where
they get uh extra content that's out
that's out the window and it was just
like what the next move said it's just
like when kids moves in the Nintendo
Factor killed everything that deal is
going through I was I was always I was
saying it was like 98 uh 98 chance that
it was going to go through and and then
kind of like when I had to step back and
I said 90 percent
the lowest is 85 percent I I just can't
see this now because when you have Gabe
somebody who's dealing with PC they're
not even in they're not even dealing
with the console uh big three he's even
taking shots at Sony that's telling you
that the industry themselves is looking
at Sony and saying oh bruh now if you
mess around vulnerable Mega yeah they
look vulnerable bro they look very if
you and you messing with people's money
so so the uh the Saudi Arabians 10 cent
and so many other embracer group all
these other all these other these these
Publishers are sitting here even rock
stars they rubbing their hands it's like
oh okay okay it's it's a fiasco it is an
absolute Fiasco uh you cannot be the
market leader and cry and moan like you
are over one game over one game that's
and that is insane to me so uh my other
point my last point is this is Dad where
I've seen a lot of Xbox Gamers getting
frustrated because they were saying oh
Xbox is still trying to do the Kumbaya
they should just break the deal because
they shouldn't give concessions this is
the thing Microsoft you've got and it's
like what you were saying dirt Microsoft
played this like a fiddle they were so
meticulous they were playing chess they
don't want see this is what this is what
Sony wanted them to do Flex come on Flex
at us Flex at us because what we you do
now is change a narrative oh we're the
so we're Sony we're the smaller company
look at this big conglomerate trying to
step all over us look at what this and
then that kind of change public
perception Microsoft is saying I'm good
I'm good here here's a concession here's
three years Sony's over here they
feeling good about themselves nah we
don't want that garbage we want we we
don't even want to do to go through so
now Microsoft is saying we'll give you
10.
and if Sony is a fool
check that deal there's a possibility
that this could go to court and Sony can
and Playstation Gamers could not get Cod
think about that for a second and who do
you think that the gamers are going to
be more upset with x Microsoft or
PlayStation 4 allowing it to go this far
so it is a situation now that it's a
it's a done deal because Microsoft
played chess they said we'll go to the
to the true number one console leader
which is Nintendo and we'll go to steam
just to let people know we're here for
everybody and it also in 10 years in a
company's sake is nothing it's nothing
for us it might be a little you know
sometimes a decade but in the company
years that's nothing and Microsoft can
maneuver and do things like yeah we can
put out war zone and we can kind of hold
our card games like like uh EA holds the
um the Battlefield games for two to
three years you know what I'm saying so
it all works out for for Microsoft
either way and they're going to get all
that money and resources to come right
back into adding games to the game pass
and for development through all their
other Studios it is a crazy win uh crazy
crazy win today and to see Phil uh to
say what he said and people keep
thinking that Phil is soft in this net
it's like a point I said in my video I
said Phil just dropped the Xbox One X
for no reason I thought it was going to
be extended it's going to have extended
life into this generation no Phil just
wanted to prove to everybody out there
that Sony will never get the power
narrative talk ever again just throwing
I'm just throwing the Xbox series the
Xbox One X out there to let you know
Sony you ain't gonna play you're not
going to win this game we're we're not
going to have this the two things that
field cannot stand was hearing that Xbox
didn't have no games and that Sony had
the more powerful console that's it yeah
it's it's a wrap this is the beginning
of of uh of a Changing of the Guard I've
been saying this and it and I know King
has been saying it but now Sony looks
more vulnerable than we've ever seen
before and now you got people without
yeah you got pinnamon out selling God of
War oh my God hey Sparks they have no
damn games he's here man you know what's
crazy the fact that people sit there
they'll talk all this smack about play
about Xbox but there is no reason after
last generation that Xbox should be
beating them on Black Friday
especially with the only game that came
out was pendleman come on man can we
please sit here and say PlayStation
isn't as hot as they used to be they're
still hot they they're not radioactive
hard anymore yeah no no no no no no no
no no no no no it's like it's like it's
like Phil Spencer's like you know what
I'm done Plan B and you know what plan B
was it was everyone in the industry
holding their hands up and give him
energy from of the spirit ball like it's
like he's sitting there he's like
PlayStation you don't mess with me one
too many times and he's shoving that
Spirit Mom it's like it's like the end
of the Dragon Ball Z boo era where they
sitting there they uh like he was like
he's sitting there he's looking he's
like I just need you to distract him for
five minutes like right right
Phil last night dropped that rap Venom
like that was just you know that was
like you said that was an emotional like
thank God we're we're good we're in the
clear because all they because at the
FTC signs off on this before uh the end
of the year
before before they go uh before Congress
go to recess it's a wrap like everybody
else is going to be like okay cool and
if the CMA wants to continue to keep
playing games then that'll be uh then
then it'll be Sony and the CMA going to
court and you've got all the rest of the
countries in the world sitting here uh
siding with with the deal because China
is not gonna it's they're gonna they're
gonna China's gonna do the talk but
China got tension tension wants to take
over damn everything as well themselves
so it would be out of the interest to
try to stop this deal they they looking
at this as an opportunity everybody
everybody who has money to want to buy
uh Studios and Publishers they are
rubbing their hands like yes let this
deal go through so we can go ahead and
make our moves right all right let me um
there's one quote from Field Spencer
that I want to read right quick at it I
guess Phil has some type of interview on
the Apple podcast or something Jay Rock
posted this he got this one quote
there's really only been one major
opposer to the deal and it's Sony and
Sony's trying to protect their dominance
on console and the way they grow is by
making the Xbox smaller right that's
Phil Phil said how it is man right he's
saying how it is yeah and I just want to
say that they they bring out the the
pocketbook and they don't like that let
me get these superchargers we'll get up
out of here man normally I'm not on
doing podcasts later tonight but uh you
know there was a lot that happened in
one week man it was kind of crazy we got
a 20 super truck from ladysen nice to
see everyone that will bring the smoke
coming late well uh late will watch from
the top glad to see you guys addressing
this Microsoft called in the big dog
media big bank as their PR
uh I think it says and no r p r r it's
like King says man big Bank take little
Bank like five dollar scripture from uh
from Jay man I doubt Microsoft would do
this but they should pull out of the UK
If the CMA blocks this deal
um I don't know that that's that's a lot
of money that they're sacrificing I
think the the
I think if they bluffed the CMA instead
the pool I I think they would actually
you know approve before they lose
imagine but they would have to do with
all of Microsoft products not just
gaming like yo you ain't getting you
ain't getting the windows you ain't
getting cloud computing imagine how
quick that would go through the
companies yo CMA you tripping like you
approve this we ain't losing everything
for Call of Duty we ain't even in that
industry so yeah right okay so we're
gonna go ahead and get out of here man
we're gonna put the uh the outros to one
minute and 50 seconds and 25 in one
minute and 50 and 25 seconds so you know
dirt dirt man what's what's going on man
where can people find you uh check out
my channel manage dropped the video
earlier talk you know of course I was
talking a lot of trash
um about this whole situation check out
the video I'll leave it in the um chat
you know man remember yeah yeah me
actually I gotta um I'm doing on my
phone so yeah just stop by check it out
that's about it I'm about to spam it in
the chat as attic says all right kiss me
man where can people find you
ah man you can find me on YouTube
youtube.com add kids move got a couple
videos I'll be dropping some Halo hello
neighbor 2 vids as well I gotta do the
thumbnails for the other videos I was
just so sick man I couldn't do anything
no you're good um it was something I
want to say when you guys are going off
but uh it is with a zephyr I forget uh
it was about the topic earlier but good
show thanks for having me attic and um
I'm looking forward to see what happens
over the rest of the week you know we
got the game awards and I'm pretty sure
in Microsoft meeting with the FTC was
today so we should see we should get
more news before that's right for the
weekend so that was today wasn't it oh
man
I'll spam kits moves in there because uh
I I actually have one of his channel up
uh K Mega Man what where can people find
yeah man where could people yeah I put
it uh in the chat hoping you guys will
check it out uh I dropped the video as
well today
um talking about the Collins uh what
Colin talked about with uh God of War
which was shocking and then of course
with um uh with the ABK deal and what
Phil and them was saying and just all of
that so yeah check out the channel uh
come and hit me up on Twitter at kmaker4
um also do a podcast every Friday night
uh 8 P.M Central uh 9 p.m Eastern uh 6
p.m Pacific brg podcast man come check
it out we wild over there I'm gonna have
to get you guys back on uh for sure
coming up here next year uh because uh
this Friday is going to be the last show
of the year I got surgery coming up here
in about a week and a half so uh just
getting myself prepped up and ready for
that and then uh you know yeah thank you
guys man appreciate it it's always an
honor to be a part of you know greatness
you know I'm saying you know kids moved
the vet the guy that asked me to do this
stuff so PlayStation stands if you if
you still can't if you hate to see my
face you blame that dude right there in
the red shirt because he's the one to
talk about the doing it man uh and then
of course Dirk dick rickety one of the
one of the leaders of the new era out
here man in the Xbox
of course you what you do man it's
always great um and then of course with
the iron Lord stew man thank you guys
and thank you chat for checking it out
keeping it rocking man thank you so much
yeah I appreciate it and then uh two
dollar Super Chat from NC ghost of low
road I don't know man you guys know I
can't pronounce something Mega addict
big dirt big dirt oh he there's this
there's a big dirt and smooth great show
and then we got a Ten Dollar Tree from
tika's great show fellas salute I
appreciate her coming through uh uh we
will be having the IOP will be next week
there's my channel like I said go go
something man we got 230 people still in
here hit that like button let's get
those likes up a little bit man I know
some of you ain't like that chat like
that this video I know you lazy it's
okay we can all be lazy but you know
what let's be lazy on something else and
like the damn video uh but I appreciate
everyone coming through uh next uh the
17th is my birthday so I I think I'm
gonna try to get like in a Manga Stream
with some people man have a good time
you know I like I like I like playing
games on my birthday with with my online
friends because I've got no real friends
anymore you know most of them moved away
or I don't I don't really mess with them
I play Pokemon with the dude I went to
high school with so I guess that's still
a friend
he's meeting me in Pokemon let me just
put that in there there's no one way
he's he's stomping me so I appreciate
everything through and we are out of
here
thank you guys appreciate it peace out
yes we will be uh okay hold up they want
to know if you guys are streaming
tomorrow's show
um
I'll be on probably uh on a Xbox 448
Channel okay uh they'll probably be
doing it yeah WBZ will be streaming it
on my Channel having a lot of fun all
right so all their uh infos and the uh
the comment section well the chat right
now smooth will be with the iron Lords
we will be streaming uh so we will see
you all tomorrow and hopefully hopefully
Sunday we'll have some nice stuff to
talk about but I'll talk to you yeah